bien mes chers collègues nous allons
commencer notre audition de ce matin en
recevant monsieur rock Olivier Mestre
président de l'arcom
afin d'évoquer en tout cas c'est l'objet
premier de notre
audition de ce matin d'évoquer le
rapport annuel du régulateur de la
communication audiovisuel et les
numériques pour 2021 comme nous le
faisons chaque année je pense que notre
audition de ce matin débordera et ira
bien au-delà de la question du rapport
de 2021 puisque
effectivement nous avons un certain
nombre de sujets d'actualités
avec
analyser avec vous
sans les cités de manière exhaustive il
y a déjà le renouvellement prochain du
processus de processus de renouvellement
pardon des mandats des présidents de
Radio France et de France médiamonde
est aussi au cœur des débats sur les
évolutions capitalistiques du secteur
initié par la mise en vente du groupe M6
nous recevions hier Benoît curé
président de l'Autorité de la
concurrence et
bien noté qu'il y avait un certain
nombre de questions que nous lui avions
posé qui en fait qui nous a pour lequel
il vous a renvoyé aux réponses donc nous
attendons de votre part des réponses à
ces questions nous y reviendrons bien
entendu alors que l'arcom avait estimé
dans son avis rendu à l'Autorité de la
concurrence que le rapprochement entre
TF1 et M6 pouvaient être envisagé au
prix de l'adoption de certains remèdes
l'Autorité de la concurrence en a jugé
autrement comme nous l'a rappelé hier
son président les deux entreprises
concernées ce donc se retrouve donc
aujourd'hui dans une situation délicate
avec la nécessité de définir une
nouvelle stratégie dans un calendrier
extrêmement contraint cette situation
interpelle législateurs que nous sommes
car elles s'inscrit dans un paysage dont
semble absent l'initiative publique le
précédent quinquennat n'a pas permis en
effet de moderniser véritablement la loi
de 1986 sur les questions de concurrence
et de réglementation de la production
afin des adapter à l'arrivée des
plateformes la réforme de l'audiovisuel
public n'a pas n'a pas abouti tandis que
la réforme de son financement est au
milieu du gué l'avenir du secteur de
l'audiovisuel dans son ensemble sont
donc dépendent de décision prise par des
investisseurs qui ne sont pas tous
Français et des autorités indépendantes
dont le rôle n'est pas de définir une
politique industrielle comme la rappeler
hier le président de l'Autorité de la
concurrence peut-être pourrez-vous nous
dire monsieur le Président ce que vous
attendez de l'État et du législateur
pour essayer de sortir de cette
situation quelles sont selon vous les
urgences
au chapitre des urgences le conflit qui
perdure entre Canal+ et TF1 sur la
distribution constitue pour nous un
autre sujet de préoccupation le
différence semble aujourd'hui porter
autant sur une question commerciale que
sur la maîtrise des contenus à travers
les univers applicatifs des deux acteurs
que peut faire le régulateur pour
favoriser un compromis faut-il envisager
une disposition législative pour assurer
que l'ensemble des Français
pourront recevoir les chaînes de la TNT
en dépit des désaccords commerciaux
entre les acteurs
je vous autant de questions que nous
souhaitons sur lequel nous souhaitons
vous entendre monsieur le Président je
vous proposerai monsieur le Président de
revenir sur ces différents aspects dans
un bref propos liminaire après quoi vous
serez interrogé par notre rapporteur
pour les crédits du visuels et bien sûr
chacun des chacune des sénatrices et
sénateurs qui le souhaiteront pourront
également intervenir je rappelle enfin
que cette audition est captée est
diffusée en direct sur le site du Sénat
monsieur le Président je vous donne la
parole
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président
Mesdames laissées natrices monsieur les
sénateurs c'est avec grand plaisir que
je retrouve ce matin votre votre
commission pour l'audition
traditionnelle sur notre rapport
d'activité c'est pour moi toujours un
plaisir de vous retrouver votre
commission ayant nous le savons un rôle
particulièrement actif sur les questions
qui relèvent de notre champ de
compétence comme chaque année ce moment
sera l'occasion d'un échange vous l'avez
dit monsieur le Président sur
l'actualité de notre institution d'une
institution qui est toute neuve nous
sommes la dernière des autorités
administratives
créées par le législateur puisque
l'arcom est né le 1er janvier dernier
je souhaite d'emblé vous dire que notre
autorité est pleinement en ordre de
marche depuis le 1er janvier grâce à un
travail de préfiguration qui avait été
menée de longue date tout au long de
l'année précédente et une pleine
adhésion à la fois des équipes de la 2
pi et de ses dirigeants et des équipes
et des dirigeants du CSA donc dès le
premier janvier nous étions en ordre de
marche avec un collège qui est désormais
élargie à 9 mois de membres de plus
je tiens à souligner que c'est un
collège
dont les membres sont désignés par 5
autorités différentes
accentuant donc si besoin en était
encore son indépendance
l'organisation de l'institution a été
également revue pour vraiment croiser
les compétences du CS de l'ancien CSA et
de l'ancien adoptique pour vraiment
marier les compétences parce contenter
d'une simple juxtaposition
nous conservons je le dis devant les
sénateurs aujourd'hui notre
représentation en région avec 16
antennes régionales donc quatre
outre-mer qui nous permet d'être au
contact et au plus près des médias de
proximité je pense en particulier au
radio et télévision locale qui jouent un
rôle important dans la vitesse
audiovisuelle du pays
une autorité je le rappelle qui avec les
deux les deux autorités fusionnées
rassemble 355 agents et nous avons
élaboré depuis le 1er janvier donc à un
projet stratégique que nous allons
adopter de façon de façon imminente au
sein du collège pour bien fixer les
priorités de cette nouvelle institution
et les orientations prioritaires pour
les pour les trois prochaines années et
bien évidemment j'aurais l'occasion de
vous communiquer ce document alors
depuis sa mise en place ça sera mon
premier point l'institution est à pied
d'oeuvre pour déployer les nouvelles
compétences que vous nous avez confié
vous savez que le Parlement nous a
confié nombreuses nouvelles missions au
cours de la législature écoulée 8 textes
de loi sont venus croiser le la route de
l'institution
négligeable et je veux commencer
d'emblée par la lutte contre le piratage
des contenus culturels et sportifs parce
que c'est un domaine sur lequel le Sénat
a joué un rôle très très important vous
êtes beaucoup investi sur ce sur ce
sujet et je vais vous dire d'emblée qui
est dispositions législatives que vous
avez que vous avez adopté
remplissent pleinement leur rôle je
rappelle que le manque a gagné les
pratiques illégales étaient estimées
pour l'année écoulée à un milliard
d'euros c'est énormément d'argent de
manque à gagner pour la création pour
les ayants droits des manifestations
sportives et le nouveau cadre juridique
que nous déployons nous permet d'avoir
une action beaucoup plus rapide beaucoup
plus réactive grâce à un dialogue bien
organisé entre le juge
les ayants droits de ces manifestations
les fournisseurs d'accès et nous-mêmes
et c'est un cadre qui nous permet en
particulier d'agir très très rapidement
pour les manifestations sportives
les ayants droits donc peuvent saisir le
juge maintenant aux fins de blocage et
de des référencements des services qui
définissent des manifestations de
manière illicie
à l'issue de la décision du juge donc
les fournisseurs d'accès peuvent
bloc ici et encadré apparition de sites
miroirs ce qui est souvent le cas en la
matière cette fois c'est l'autorité
administrative qui peut demander le
blocage des sites
depuis le 1er janvier vous donner un
ordre de grandeur ce sont plus de 806
qui ont été bloqués de cette manière
permettant de diminuer de 50% le
piratage sportif au cours du premier
semestre donc si vous voulez vous dire
l'impact des mesures que vous avez
votées je tenais à le souligner
j'imagine que vous avez eu où vous aurez
l'occasion d'entendre les représentants
des ayants droits donc je pense à Canal+
ou BeIn Sport pour ce secteur qui vous
diront leur satisfaction et nous sommes
engagés maintenant avec les fournisseurs
d'accès et les représentants des ayants
droits dans une procédure qui nous
permettra d'automatiser la chaîne pour
encore aller plus vite dans dans le
blocage des sites
donc première premier chantier que nous
avons mis en oeuvre sans délai deuxième
chantier de la supervision des
plateformes en ligne donc
occuper également une place importante
dans notre activité d'abord la lutte
contre la manipulation de l'information
qui était bien sûr un sujet
particulièrement sensible en période
électorale nous allons publier vers la
mi-octobre je pense et vous en serez
naturellement destinataire le troisième
bilan d'application de la loi dite un
fox ou anti infox de décembre 2018
et vous verrez que les enseignements la
Commission nationale de contrôle de
l'élection présidentielle a d'ailleurs
salué ce point-là que cette régulation
commence on pourra y revenir au cours de
l'audition apporter ses fruits nos
compétences ont été vous le savez aussi
complétés par la loi du 24 août 2021
confortant les respects des principes de
la République et puis surtout cette
régulation des plateformes a pris une
dimension européenne très forte avec
l'élaboration qui est enfin l'adoption
qui est en phase finale maintenant
est vraisemblablement la publication du
texte avant avant la fin du mois de
décembre de cette année du nouveau
règlement européen sur les services
numériques auxquels nous avons contribué
activement dans le cadre du groupe des
régulateurs européens
nous sommes très impliqués
et nous suivons donc maintenant nous
allons suivre de très près la mise en
oeuvre de ce texte qui ouvre vraiment
une nouvelle frontière je dirais pour la
régulation de ces acteurs
même si on peut toujours souhaiter aller
plus loin c'est une étape très très
importante
de ce point de vue nous souhaitons pour
notre part que l'autorité de
Coordination française qui est prévue
dans ce règlement européen donc sur le
site de DSC
puisse être désigné rapidement je
l'évoque devant vous parce que ce sera
une compétence du législateur il faudra
un petit texte de loi pour désigner
cette autorité et donc au regard de la
compétence que nous avons acquise ces
dernières années du dialogue très nourri
que nous avons avec les plateformes il
nous semble il reviendra au législateur
dans décidé que l'arcane pourrait être
cette autorité de coordination nationale
en liaison bien sûr avec les autres
autorités concernées par ces sujets je
pense en particulier à la CNIL
je l'évoque ce dossier parce pour vous
dire quand même que la dimension
européenne de la régulation va
aujourd'hui croissant
nous avons devant nous un nouveau texte
qui a été déposé par la Commission
européenne on pourra peut-être en dire
un mot également il y a quelques jours
encore seulement sur la liberté des
médias donc l'INFA
nous serons nous-mêmes impliqués dans le
dans le bord de
comité de pilotage de les gars à compter
de raconter de l'année prochaine vous
pouvez jouer un rôle crucial et au titre
de la dimension internationale de
l'activité donc je vous indique que je
prendrai début octobre la présidence du
réseau des régulateurs francophones
réunissons tous les présidents de
l'ensemble des autorités francophones
notamment du continent africain
et je prendrai la présidence de cette
institution et ça sera l'occasion bien
sûr de partager nos expériences et
notamment les modèles européens sur la
régulation des plateformes
troisième domaine nouveau pour nous
c'est d'actualité avec la publication
d'un rapport par le Sénat hier soir
c'est une mission particulière de
protection des mineurs face aux contre
au contenu pornographique donc je
rappelle que nous avons mis en demeure
cette sites les plus importants en
l'occurrence contre venant au
dispositions de la loi adoptée sur
amendement du Sénat en 2000 en 2020
nous avons par ailleurs saisi le
tribunal judiciaire on constatant que
les mises en demeures n'avaient pas été
suivies des faits une audience s'est
tenue donc tout récemment le 8 septembre
et le juge pour à ce stade décider de
recourir une procédure de médiation donc
il va démarrer là dans les jours qui
viennent nous avons souhaité que cette
médiation soit d'une durée relativement
courte parce que le temps depuis
l'adoption de la loi
c'était cool et c'est cool vite
et donc la balle à nos yeux et
maintenant dans le camp des sites
j'espère que cette médiation sera
l'occasion pour eux de proposer des
dispositifs efficaces répondant à la
volonté du législateur qui s'est encore
exprimé hier soir à travers ce rapport
nouvelle compétences également et pas
des plus légères si je puis employer cet
adjectif nous déployons une autre
mission depuis l'entrée en vigueur du
règlement terrorisme qui est la
supervision de la lutte contre les
contenus terroristes et
pédopornographiques
un membre du collège de l'arcom donc est
une magistrate judiciaire qui a été
désigné par la le premier président de
la Cour de cassation prend en charge
donc la mission qui était autrefois
assurée par la CNIL de contrôle des
demandes de blocage de retrait et de des
référencesments des sites d'apologie du
terrorisme et de pédopornographie qui
sont adressées par la plateforme Pharos
une plateforme du
ministère de l'Intérieur
l'ordre de grandeur je le cite devant
vous et spectaculaire j'avoue j'en étais
moi-même très impressionné c'était quand
même plus de 130 000 contenus qui ont dû
être vérifiés au titre de l'année 2021
des chiffres qui sont d'ailleurs en
augmentation quand on regarde les
statistiques de la CNIL sur ces sur ces
dernières années
donc vous le voyez une institution qui
est pleinement d'ordre de marge depuis
sa création et qui
mute progressivement pour bien épouser
son temps pour bien épouser son époque
et notamment dans l'univers dans
l'univers digital
mais bien sûr ce sera mon second point
l'arcom a été tout aussi active sur ces
missions traditionnelles avec des
dossiers majeurs qui nous ont occupés
ces derniers mois qui nous occupent
encore très activement en particulier
depuis cette rentrée
2021 2022 ont d'abord été marqué pour
nous par des échéances électorales de
premier plan les élections régionales le
troisième référendum en
Nouvelle-Calédonie le scrutin
présidentiel et les élections
législatives et dans le cadre de notre
mission de préservation du pluralisme
politique à long terme nous avons veillé
de très près au bon déroulement de ces
rendez-vous démocratiques majeurs sur
les chaînes de télévision et de radio
nous allons là aussi publier comme nous
le faisons après chaque élection
nationale notre bilan de cette période
qui comprendra pour la première fois
j'ai fait deux ans tout à l'heure un
volet sur les plateformes en ligne que
nous avons impliqué cette fois-ci dans
le processus nous avions réuni toutes
les plateformes dès le mois de janvier
nous avons redis tous les 15 jours
pendant le processus électoral et sans
vous le verrez on note de vrais progrès
notamment par rapport à la période 2017
sans dévoiler le contenu de ce rapport
je veux souligné devant vous que les
médias audiovisuels ont joué un rôle
majeur pour ces élections période post
pandémie
vous le savez il y a eu beaucoup moins
de meetings politiques il y en a
traditionnellement en période de
campagne électorale pour des raisons
évidentes le débat c'est largement
concentré à travers les médias du
visuels le volume de programme consacré
à la campagne a été a été tout à fait
significative et
même si on a été obligé ici ou là de
faire quelques quelques rappels au
regard du principe du pluralisme
globalement les choses se sont
correctement déroulées nous serons
peut-être amenés à faire dans le rapport
que j'évoquais dans le bilan que
j'évoquais quelques propositions tout de
même d'amélioration
des principes et des règles que nous
déployons vous avez toutes ces règles
sont pour l'essentiel fixées par la loi
elle-même donc le régulateur a une
marche de manoeuvre qui est assez
restreinte
mais c'est vrai qu'avec le développement
des réseaux sociaux et l'évolution du
paysage peut-être que certaines de ses
règles pourraient gagner à être revisité
donc en tout cas on s'attachera de force
de provisions je crois que le Sénat
lui-même envisage d'engager un travail
sur sur les sondages donc ce sera
peut-être l'occasion si la mission
parlementaire qui lancera ses travaux le
souhaitent de nous entendre et nous
pourrons partager nos réflexions sur le
sur le sujet
dans une période
à l'actualité nationale et
internationale très dense notre
vigilance aussi était constante pour
veiller bien sûr à notre première
mission il y a la liberté d'expression à
la rigueur de l'information à la
maîtrise de l'antenne on a été amené
donc à faire un certain nombre
d'interventions auprès des médias
sous forme de mise en demeure ou de ou
de mise en garde comme nous le faisons
traditionnellement de même dans le
contexte très particulier que nous
traversons de la guerre
ukrainienne nous avons contribué de
manière très active pour la France enfin
même de manière
décisive à la mise en oeuvre des
sanctions qui avaient été adoptées par
le Conseil de l'Union européenne à
l'encontre notamment des chaînes RT
France et
erossia 24 et vous avez vu qu'on a par
ailleurs mis en demeure la société
hôtels sat donc l'opérateur satellitaire
européen de cesser la diffusion de NTV
mire qui était une chaîne relayant
activement la propagande russe et qui à
nos yeux en freinait les règles dont
nous sommes dont nous sommes chargés
au-delà de ces missions liées au
pluralisme et à la déontologie des
programmes l'arcom a aussi continué à
accompagner la transformation des médias
je pense qu'on va y revenir au cours de
cette édition transformation du paysage
sont sont très fortes je commencerai
peut-être par la radio à laquelle les
Français sont très attachés c'est le
média qui a leur préférence dans les
sondages d'opinion il l'écoute beaucoup
trois quarts des Français écoute la
radio tous les jours en moyenne
quotidienne deux heures et 42 minutes je
me demande parfois où est-ce qu'il
trouve le temps mais c'est en tout cas
la statistique moyenne c'est un média
qui a célébré ses 100 ans l'année
dernière on avait souhaité à cette
occasion organiser une fête de la radio
et c'est l'occasion bien sûr de
réfléchir à l'avenir de ce média et
comme vous le savez donc le régulateur
a accélérer très fortement le
déploiement de la radio numérique
toute chose égale par ailleurs un peu
l'équivalent de ce qui a été dans les
années 2000 la TNT pour la télévision
donc ce qu'on appelle le DAB+ du nombre
de la norme qui a connu une avancée
importante qui va encore connaître une
avancée significative cette année
puisque on pense fin 2023 couvrir 50% de
la population
métropolitaine qui sont couvertes par
cette nouvelle norme de diffusion et qui
a permet à la fois d'améliorer le
confort d'écoute notamment en mobilité
puisque le signal au circulé notamment
sur l'autoroute le signal vous suit en
permanence sans qu'on ait la perte de
fréquence qui se met à grésiller
je l'évoque devant vous parce que dans
cette phase de déploiement vous savez
notre paysage radiophonique comportait
énormément de radio associative de radio
de proximité vous les connaissez dans
vos dans vos territoires c'est pour elle
une charge quand même puisqu'elle doit
assumer les coûts de diffusion en
modulation de fréquence et les coûts de
diffusion maintenant en DAB+ le temps
que le DAB+ se déploie vraiment
et donc nous quand même l'idée d'un
accompagnement de ces radios plus
fragiles de ces radios associatives dans
cette phase de déploiement et de même
nous avons incité tous ces acteurs
maintenant ils l'ont fait parce qu'ils
viennent de créer une association en ce
sens de déployer une communication
active pour mieux faire connaître le DAB
plus au grand public
toujours en radio nous avons un dossier
en cours aussi important
quelle évolution de la gouvernance et de
la nature des activités radiophoniques
du groupe Lagardère à la suite de l'EPA
de Vivendi donc un dossier qui est je
crois vous l'avez entendu hier
en partie enfin en partie qui était à
l'aide vraiment la Commission de
Bruxelles mais qui aura pour nous un
volet un voleur radiophonique puisque
tout changement de contrôle d'un
opérateur qui détient une autorisation
doit être agréée par le régulateur
et naturellement la transformation du
secteur
concerne très directement la télévision
vous êtes particulièrement faite ce
dossier mais je pense au projet
désormais abandonnés de fusion entre TF1
et M6 qui a bien sûr mobilisé très
activement et les services et le collège
de l'autorité pendant pendant plusieurs
mois
nous avons souhaité rendre publique
notre avis bien que l'Autorité de la
concurrence n'est pas rendu de décision
sur ce dossier puisque les demandeurs
ont retiré leur dossier donc n'a pas eu
à statuer on sait le président a eu
l'occasion de vendre votre commission
d'exposer le raisonnement qui était le
sien mais il y a pas eu formellement de
décision sur ce dossier il nous a paru
quand même utile parce que c'est
transparent de rendre public la vie que
nous avions rendu à l'autorité la
concurrence j'ajoute tout de suite pour
nous c'était qu'une toute petite partie
du dossier
la loi prévoit une double procédure une
procédure devant l'Autorité de la
concurrence et une procédure d'agrément
des changements de contrôle devant
devant leur com au titre de la procédure
devant l'Autorité de la concurrence
celle-ci a souhaité connaître notre avis
au regard de ses compétences propres du
droit de la concurrence et donc nous
l'avons vu un avis sur la problématique
des marchés marchés de la publicité
marché de la distribution marché des
droits aimer bien évidemment au titre de
la pro de changement de contrôle
d'agrément du changement de contrôle
pour lequel la loi nous impose de
réaliser une étude d'impact nous étions
mis en ordre de marche pour préparer et
publier cette étude d'impact et bien
évidemment pour faire part très
explicitement de nos attentes en matière
de pluralisme qui est le cœur de notre
mission pluralisme au sens large
d'ailleurs c'est plus réalise bien
évidemment de
préservation de la pluralité des
courants de pensée et d'opinion à la
garde d'acteurs qui concentre une part
importante de l'information mais aussi
pluralité les guichets de financement de
la de la création donc c'est à vie ne
donne qu'une partie de la vie si je puis
dire de l'autorité sur l'ensemble de
cette opération mais la deuxième partie
bien évidemment c'est interrompu puisque
le dossier a été retiré par les
protagonistes on pourra on pourra y
revenir
nous sommes engagés du coup pleinement
déjà depuis depuis quelques temps pour
en reparler au cours de cette audition
sur la procédure de renouvellement des
autorisations
respectives de TF1 et M6 qui comme vous
le savez arrive à échéance au mois de
mai 2023 donc il y a un compte à rebours
calendaire qui est dans ces déjà
enclenché
une consultation publique des acteurs du
secteur est en cours on a laissé un
petit peu plus de temps aux acteurs
contenus de la décision de Bouygues et
de retirer son son dossier donc cette
consultation publique prendra fin le 10
octobre prochain à l'issue de cela donc
nous allons au vu des contributions que
nous allons recevoir élaborer notre
étude d'impact que prévoit que prévoit
la loi qui sera naturellement publié
conformément au texte législatif
et puis ensuite il y aura la procédure
d'appel à candidature formelle examen
des candidatures sélection
après audition et négociation des
conventions des futurs titulaires de ces
autorisations donc c'est un chantier
très lourd de longue haleine et
inutile de le souligner devant vous afin
nous menons en parallèle donc comme vous
le voyez on ne chôme pas loin de là le
renouvellement en cours de
l'autorisation de Canal+ puisque Canal+
est arrivé en fin d'autorisation elle
aussi en 2023 la chaîne a souhaité que
son autorisation soit renouvelée ce qui
était son droit et nous avons répondu à
ce drame et nous sommes maintenant dans
la phase de finalisation de la
convention liée au renouvellement de
cette autorisation
aux côtés des acteurs privés
l'audiovisuel public et lui aussi engagé
dans un processus de transformation vous
savez combien le larcome est attaché au
service public la loi nous charge de
veiller à son indépendance et au
pluralisme de l'audiovisuel public
je rappelle que c'est 30% de l'audience
en radio comment télévision c'est un
poids économique de l'ordre de 4
milliards et demi qui est un petit peu
plus faible que le poids économique du
service public en Angleterre ou ou en
Allemagne mais c'est des acteurs et des
Sociétés nationales qui jouent un rôle
fondamental dans l'équilibre du paysage
audiovisuel en matière d'information ou
en matière de d'offre de programme avec
un soutien en particulier décisif pour
le financement de la création et donc
nous sommes très attentifs on a fait
plusieurs reprises connaître notre
opinion y compris devant votre
commission vous vous la savez vous le
savez attentif aux financement de
l'audiovisuel public
nous avons vu les choix qui ont été
opérés notamment pour la loi de finances
pour pour 2000 pour 2023
et nous serons bien évidemment on va
pouvoir en parler j'imagine très
attentif à la suite à l'avenir du
service public
et nous souhaitons de ce point de vue là
que la période qui s'ouvre on aurait
peut-être d'ailleurs souhaité qu'on
commence par ça soit l'occasion d'avoir
une vraie réflexion sur quelle vision
avons-nous du service public qu'elle
ambition avant nous sur le service
public qu'elle organisation
souhaite-t-on pour le service public
quel gouvernance envisage-t-on et donc
qu'elle financement souhaite tant pour
ce service public donc nous souhaitons
que la période qui s'ouvre soit
notamment à travers les débats
parlementaires l'occasion de cette
réflexion
je pourrais pas énumérer tous les
dossiers mais je souhaite quand même
évoquer quelques dossiers qui sont
également en cours les premiers
concernent nos compétences en matière de
cohésion sociale
j'en cite un parce qu'il est nouveau
c'est la mise en oeuvre de la loi climat
et résilient ce que vous avez le
Parlement a adopté
ce texte prévoit la conclusion de charte
d'engagement les acteurs de la publicité
sous l'égide du législateur pour tendre
une publicité plus verte pour résumer
les choses une formule à ramassée cette
mission
conforte notre action pour réduire
l'empreinte environnementale des acteurs
du visuel numérique vous savez qu'on
travaille sur ces sujets conjointement
avec avec leur recette et donc on a
coordonné les acteurs de l'audiovisuel
aussi pour qu'il conclut ses chartes ils
ont déposé
sur le site du ministère de
l'Environnement les engagements qu'ils
ont pris que ce soit au titre de leur
gouvernance propre leur RSE ou que ce
soit à travers les programmes qu'ils
portent pour faire partager par les
Français les bonnes pratiques à avoir au
regard de la problématique de la
transition numérique deuxième dossier
que j'évoque aussi qui nous a beaucoup
occupé c'est le soutien à la création
française
vous savez tout le cadre réglementaire a
été révisé donc les décrets
SMAD TNT CAPSAT donc nous amène à
revoir à revoir notamment les
conventions qui nous liées aux
opérateurs le point central ça a été la
conclusion pour une première période de
convention avec les grands acteurs
américains qui ciment notre territoire
donc Netflix Amazon Prime Disney plus
pour ne citer que cela mais il y en a
d'autres
c'est un dossier qui est en dans une
phase de mouvement continue la question
de la chronologie des médias est bien
évidemment un sujet très important ce
qu'il faut retenir quand même
aujourd'hui c'est que ce qui est en
œuvre au titre de la transposition de la
directive SMA est aujourd'hui unique
suivante unique en Europe le niveau de
financement que nous avons
collectivement par la transposition de
cette directive par les textes
réglementaires qui ont été mis en oeuvre
par l'action du régulateur et par
l'implication des opérateurs le niveau
de financement n'a aucun équivalent dans
les pays de l'Union celui qui nous suit
mais encore de loin c'est l'Italie et
donc l'exception culturelle française a
été très fortement très fortement
défendu et préservé par le travail
collectif des autorités françaises il
faut je crois sans s'en réjouir
voilà donc vous voyez depuis sa création
l'arcom a donc déployé ses missions
nouvelles poursuivi ces missions
historiques
un petit mot puisque j'ai la chance
d'être devant vous aujourd'hui et que le
débat parlementaire va bientôt commencer
vous savez que depuis bonne dizaine
d'années maintenant le torité à assurer
le déploiement de ses missions et
notamment de ses missions nouvelles à
effectif et budget constant
et une fois n'est pas coutume donc nous
avons sollicité un renforcement de nos
moyens pour porter les nombreuses et
nouvelles missions et complexe mission
parce que c'est de les régulations d'un
genre nouveau qui nous faut maintenant
déployer au titre de la loi de finances
pour pour 2023
le projet de loi de finance nous a nous
a ce stade entendu et j'espère en tout
cas je sollicite le concours de
l'ensemble des formations politiques qui
sont représentées au parlement pour
venir à l'appui de notre de notre action
bien sûr à votre disposition pour
répondre à toutes vos questions merci
monsieur le Président et nous allons
commencer la série de questions par
celle de Jean Raymond Hugonnet
rapporteur
décrédibilités
merci président merci président pour ce
voilà ce panorama cette synthèse de
l'activité
de l'arcome comme l'a dit le président
Lafont dans son propos luminaire
l'autorité que vous précisez l'arcome
avait indiqué que des remèdes
raisonnables
pouvaient permettre de répondre aux
préoccupations sectorielles suscité par
le projet de rapprochement je vise bien
évidemment l'actualité encore fraîche
comment expliquer vous la divergence
d'analyses avec l'Autorité de la
concurrence et pensez-vous toujours que
cette fusion était possible on regarde
du droit et de l'intérêt du secteur
par ailleurs le groupe berthelsman
semble décider à poursuivre la session
de M6 dans les plus brefs délais
plusieurs candidats ont manifesté leur
intérêt vendredi dernier certains ayant
déjà une présence dans les médias
d'autres pouvant être considérés comme
des nouveaux entrants
quel serait la durée minimale d'examen
par la com d'un nouveau projet de
rapprochement
est-ce que le calendrier serait plus
long si l'acheteur est déjà un acteur
important du secteur des médias
et est-ce qu'il y a un risque que
l'examen par les différents régulateurs
ne soient pas achevés avant le début du
printemps étant donné ce calendrier très
très contraint enfin est-ce que
qu'est-ce qui pourrait amener l'arcome à
ne pas renouveler en mail à licence du
nouveau propriétaire de M6
concernant toujours et c'est ma
troisième et dernier question concernant
toujours nos différents qui opposent TF1
et Canal+ on peut rappeler que le
législateur avait renoncé à agir en 2018
lors d'un précédent conflit de même
nature afin de ne pas avoir à se
prononcer sur le principe de la
rémunération du signal des chaînes de la
TNT
ne pensez-vous pas que l'adoption d'une
disposition législative concernant
l'extension du mustari que vous semblez
appeler de vos vœux
risque de rouvrir le débat sur le
principe même de la rémunération du
signal on peut en effet rappeler que les
chaînes publiques ne font pas l'objet
d'une rémunération pour leur signal et
que cela constitue une forme de
contrepartie à l'obligation de
distribution dont elle bénéficie
du Président je vais vous laisser
répondre à cette première série question
merci beaucoup monsieur le rapporteur
permettez-moi de prendre un petit temps
pour pour répondre à votre première
question
pour redire je l'ai exposé dans
rapidement dans mon propos libinners que
la procédure d'instruction de ce projet
de fusion qui était bien évidemment
chacun en a conscience un enjeu majeur
pour le paysage audiovisuel français
se traduisait par une double instruction
parallèle une instruction devant
l'Autorité de la concurrence d'une part
au titre de son champ de compétences qui
est le droit le droit de la concurrence
qui est applicable dans notre dans notre
pays et puis la procédure de changement
de contrôle et d'agrément du changement
de contrôle devant l'arcom conformément
la loi c'est deux procédures qui
cheminaient en parallèle chacune avec sa
problématique droit de la concurrence du
côté de l'autorité de la concurrence
principe posé par la loi de 86 au titre
des médias audiovisuels et qui se résume
par un mot qui est celui du pluralisme
au sens large du terme qui est vraiment
le cœur le cœur du métier du régulateur
que nous sommes
au titre de sa mission donc l'autorité
de la concurrence a souhaité recueillir
la vie de plusieurs autorités le nôtre
celui de celui de la recette s'affaire
de ma part je crois qu'ils ont également
consulté la CNIL et donc nous avons
répondu à la demande de l'autorité de la
concurrence avec un avis très
circonstancié
et si les membres de la commission en
ont le loisir et le temps
j'en conseille volontiers la lecture
d'abord c'est ta vie dit très clairement
en préambule donc c'est l'avertissement
chapeau qui a bien deux procédures et
que sur notre champ de compétence qui
n'est pas couvert par cet avis le marcom
aurait été amené à donner un avis
spécifique sur la façon dont nous voyons
la problématique du pluralisme au regard
de cette opération nous sommes contentés
de répondre à l'Autorité de la
concurrence sur les problématiques de
nature économique qui sont de sa
compétence c'est bien ça l'objet et donc
l'analyse qui était la nôtre comme
régulateur sectoriel des marchés de la
publicité du marché de la distribution
et du marché des différents droits de
production cinéma audiovisuel sportif
on a construit cet avis vous le verrez
c'est la vie volumineux il fait une
centaine de pages en deux parties une
première partie c'est peut-être ça là
que j'inviterai les membres de votre
commission à regarder attentivement
au-delà de la synthèse une synthèse est
toujours bien sur un parfait
la première partie elle est consacrée à
analyser le paysage audiovisuel tel que
nous le voyons aujourd'hui en étant le
plus prospectif qu'on puisse l'être à la
date d'aujourd'hui un exercice toujours
difficile rien n'a plus difficile qu'une
prédire l'avenir et on a essayé de voir
quels étaient les tendances de fond qui
était aujourd'hui à l'oeuvre dans le
paysage et vous verrez dans ce panorama
il est impressionnant de voir les
évolutions qui sont aujourd'hui à
l'oeuvre et je crois je vais le dire
plus de reprises depuis je préside cette
autorité qu'on aurait tort de
sous-estimer ces évolutions je le dis à
la fois pour le secteur privé et je le
dis aussi pour le secteur public
c'est des entreprises qui aujourd'hui
doivent s'adapter à un environnement qui
se traduit par une très profondévolution
des usages on a une baisse continue de
la durée écoute
individuel des téléspectateurs l'arrivée
de nouveaux acteurs le fait que les
écrans sont maintenant connectés à 80 %
que les usages sont beaucoup plus
fracturés six écrans moyen de par forêt
par foyer donc il y a vraiment des
tendances de fonds et donc il en résulte
une obligation pour les acteurs publics
comme privé j'insiste bien sur le fait
que ça concerne tout autant le service
public de pouvoir dégager les capacités
d'investissement requises pour faire à
la fois les investissements
technologiques nécessaires pour toucher
les publics là où ils sont
le public de la télévision vieillit
dangereusement aujourd'hui c'est un
enjeu majeur pour le privé comme pour le
pour le public et en même temps qu'on
sentir les investissements nécessaires
pour financer une création de haut
niveau pour faire face aux évolutions
aux évolutions du paysage et une
augmentation à l'augmentation des coûts
en particulier du fait de la concurrence
croissante qui règne entre les acteurs
donc c'est une première partie en disant
voilà aujourd'hui quel est le paysage
dans lequel on est et voilà un peu les
tendances qui sont les nôtres et puis
dans une deuxième partie on a identifié
les risques que comporter cette
opération et cette opération comporter
des risques comporter des risques en
matière de publicité la signaler et vu
de notre point de vue comporter un
risque au titre du pluralisme externe et
c'est ça qu'on a traité dans cet avis le
pluralisme externe c'est quoi c'est quel
effet cette opération aurait eu sur les
autres acteurs de la TNT vous savez que
le chien de la TNT sont en mauvaise
situation économique fragile TF1 M6 ce
sont des chaînes solides qui
fonctionnent bien mais cette opération
aurait eu des conséquences au titre du
marché publicitaire sur les acteurs les
plus fragiles donc on a soulevé comme
régulateur sectoriel ce risque lié à
cette opération et on a évoqué
on n'a pas eu la présomption la
prétention pardon de vouloir se
substituer à l'autorité de la
concurrence dont on savait par nature
que c'était le métier j'ajoute qu'on a
les meilleurs relations avec cette
autorité avec lesquelles les relations
sont à la fois très confiantes très
fluide et vraiment de de très bon aloi
voilà on a évoqué une petite série de
familles de remèdes dont des remèdes
structurels je signale qu'on évoquait
des sessions de chaîne supplémentaires
par exemple ça n'a pas été relevé les
directions générales de la concurrence
la relevée elle-même dans son propre
dans son propre avis
donc il y avait des remèdes structurels
on a soulevé également les risques pour
la distribution
a fait de même de son côté dans une
tonalité qui celle du régulateur des
télécoms mais avec une approche qui
était grosso modo la même et on a
souligné les risques sur le marché des
droits en indiquant très clairement que
si ce cette opération devait se faire ça
supposerait qu'il y a quand même en tout
cas des remèdes suffisants pour garantir
une pluralité de guichet de financement
et surtout pour garantir une un mieux
disant culturel sur l'affaire
donc je considère pas pour ma part qui
est vraiment de différence d'approche on
a considéré nous aussi qu'il y avait des
risques on a donné notre point de vue et
notre piste de remède en tant que
régulateur sectoriel avec notre vision à
nous du paysage audiovisuel l'Autorité
de la Concurrence a donné son analyse
sur la façon dont elle voyait les
marchés de la publicité c'est sa mission
c'est son alors à partir de là les
acteurs ont retiré leur dossiers donc
pas le dossier c'est arrêté alors
j'embrasse sur votre deuxième question
j'en ai dit un mot je suis je vais pas
rentrer
dans le détail bien évidemment pour des
raisons évidentes
le dossier qui nous occupe aujourd'hui
c'est le renouvellement des
autorisations
c'est un dossier connu en début de
l'année prochaine les deux autorisations
tombent définitivement la loi nous
impose donc de repartir à zéro et de
lancer un appel à candidature avec des
étapes précédentes qui sont en cours
donc consultation publique de tous les
acteurs je l'ai dit à des temps court on
publiera une étude d'impact
exactement à quel moment ils ont coupé
courant pour enfin novembre on laissera
aux acteurs le temps de réagir à notre
étude on lancera l'appel à candidature
puis après on verra qui est candidat on
examinera ces candidatures on ne
dissynera les candidats puisque la loi
prévoit que les auditions sont publiques
et ensuite on statuera et on négociera
les conventions pour être à pied
d'oeuvre et avoir des titulaires
d'autorisation en ordre de marche à
l'échéance des autorisations actuelles
donc ça c'est notre feuille de route du
moment c'est en cours et c'est un
processus sur lequel on déroulera la loi
telle qu'elle est telle qu'elle est
fixée
alors maintenant je lis les journaux
comme vous
je vois qu'on parle d'options possibles
à la date où je vous parle nous sommes
saisit de rien
je redis simplement devant vous que si
on devait être saisi de quelque chose
aussi une opération de devait se faire
sur le changement de capital de cette
société qui est titulaire d'une
autorisation elle serait soumise donc de
par la loi à la procédure d'agrément du
changement de contrôle par leur com avec
l'obligation de refaire une étude
d'impact spécifique de rendre public
cette étude d'impact recueillir les
réactions à cette étude d'impact
le calendrier
et plus ultra serré
mais il est encore faisable
[Musique]
calendrier est extrêmement serré
vraiment extrêmement clair de devant
vous je le dis ici très clairement
le processus d'appel à candidature fixe
un compte à rebours qui rend les choses
extrêmement contraignantes extrêmement
serrées plus que serré et j'ajoute mais
le président de l'Autorité de la
concurrence là très bien d'hier soir que
nous ne pourrions statuer sur un
éventuel changement de contrôle de la
chaîne M6 qu'après que les autorités de
la concurrence qu'elles soient
bruxelloise ou nationale et statué donc
il faudrait que ces procédures
s'emboîtent donc quand je dis que le
calendrier est très serré je dis que le
calendrier est très très serré
troisième point alors TF1 canal oui
cette deuxième question oui oui très
rapidement mais j'avais rajouté que
qu'est-ce qui pourrait amener l'arcon à
ne pas renouveler en mai la licence de
M6 après anticiper sur le délibéré vous
savez c'est comme le président de la
commission des facteurs moi je gère un
collèges
c'est un collège de 9 membres avec des
personnalités fortes des services
dirigés par directeur général qui est
persuadé non moi aussi forte donc voilà
il faut laisser à l'instruction le temps
de se faire au collège le temps de
délibérer
gardons-en pour la prochaine fois
monsieur le rapporteur si vous voulez
bien
TF1 canal je vous donne le fond de ma
pensée c'est bon c'est un litigé
purement commercial purement commercial
c'est des acteurs
vous les entendez régulièrement
ils sont des adeptes de la liberté du
commerce et de l'industrie très bien que
le marché montre son efficacité que la
main invisible d'Adam Smith montre sa
capacité à résoudre le conflit
vu de notre point de vue ce qui n'est
pas acceptable je le dis devant vous
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de m'exprimer
c'est que le téléspectateur soit pris
dans un litige commercial
qui est une différentielle de prix et
une négociation
voilà je demande tellement de
rémunération je trouve que c'est trop je
te demande moins je te demande plus
voilà ça c'est les règles du marché très
bien mais le téléspectateur il a pas à
être canalisé dans cet exercice parce
que l'esprit de la TNT vous le savez
bien c'est l'accès de tous les Français
Gratuitement sur l'ensemble du
territoire y compris dans les zones
blanches dans les zones on peut pas
avoir de pylône
au signal et donc j'ai proposé aux
acteurs
l'opération dont on vient de parler
peut-être pas contribué complètement à
la sérénité des débats à plusieurs
reprises
genre d'entre vous connaissent bien un
processus de médiation
j'aurais très volontiers très volontiers
fait à ce stade nous sommes pas arrivés
ils ont préféré la voix du tribunal de
commerce le Tribunal de Commerce a rendu
une première décision une autre
procédure pendant le tribunal de
commercial initiative de canal je le dis
clairement devant vous moi je souhaite
qu'on trouve une solution et la solution
elle est à portée de main pour ce que je
connais du dossier elle est vraiment à
portée de main donc que les acteurs se
remettent autour de la table je suis
disponible 24 heures sur 24 pour le
faire dès que les deux parties le
souhaiteront et si c'est pas le cas
parce que ces affaires sont à répétition
moi je commençais à avoir l'espoir que
le marché avait mûri et que les parties
commencer avec le marché commencer à
trouver un point d'équilibre si c'est
pas le cas je l'ai dit il faudra que le
législateur complète le texte le texte
de loi pourquoi parce que la loi
actuelle donc elle impose aux éditeurs
une obligation de mettre à disposition
leur signal donc ça c'est l'esprit la
TNT donc ce que les Anglo-Saxons
appellent un must deliver donc l'éditeur
doit mettre à disposition son cylindre
mais il impose pas au distributeurs au
type de la liberté du commerce de
reprendre le signal et là dans le cas
d'espace de Canal+ le problème et c'est
ça que j'ai visé dans mon propos c'est
la diffusion satellitaire c'est pas la
négociation sur les programmes
complémentaires que portent TF1
vis-à-vis de canal c'est vraiment sur
cette diffusion satellitaire
et là je pense qu'il y a deux options il
y en a une qui était dans le dernier
projet de loi du visuel qui n'a pas été
adopté que vous connaissez bien monsieur
le rapporteur qui pouvait donner aux
régulateur un pouvoir de mesure
conservatoire dans une procédure de
règlement différente permettrait au
régulateur de dire pas de coupure de
signal maintenant on se met autour de la
table on négocie donc ça serait une
première voie de réponse
l'autre voit ça serait d'imposer au seul
diffuseur satellite alors mon idée
n'était pas un must carré comme pour le
service public au seul diffuseur
satellitaires la reprise du signal que
l'éditeur a l'obligation de mettre à
disposition bon j'espère que la raison
finira pas l'emporter c'est mon
optimisme probablement Béa mon côté
peut-être
trop optimiste mais je ne désespère
jamais de la nature humaine
[Musique]
et donner la parole maintenant à un
représentant par groupe et donc par
ordre successifs Catherine Morin de
saillie David Assouline Monique de Marco
Julien barjoton et Céline Brulin
merci président d'avoir organisé cette
audition du président de la reconnais
celle de l'Autorité de la concurrence
hier
c'était très utile car et notre
rapporteur a été notre porte-voix
face à l'incompréhension de deux avis
totalement divergences sur le
rapprochement TF1 M6 pour ma part mais
si je respecte bien entendu le travail
des autorités indépendantes la vie
qu'elles émettent j'avoue être un peu
dans une forme d'incompréhension par
rapport d'ailleurs à ce que vous avez
dit monsieur le Président il faut savoir
être prospectif savoir ce que sera le
paysage audiovisuel de demain et me
semble qu'actuellement les règles de la
concurrence d'ailleurs ça a été démontré
au niveau européen sont inadaptés à la
nouvelle concurrence des une forme à
l'air du du tout numérique et ça vaut
pour bien d'autres secteurs d'ailleurs
que le seul secteur
audiovisuel donc on a l'impression que
le grand bénéficiaire de ça ça va être
en fait le marché publicitaire et non
pas les éditeurs de programme dont
dépend ce marché d'ailleurs publicitaire
donc on a l'impression que c'est avoir
une vision court termiste des choses moi
je voudrais vous interroger plus
particulièrement sur votre
réorganisation à l'époque quand nous
avions parlé de la fusion hadopie CSA
nous envisagions aussi à un
rapprochement avec la recette pas une
fusion d'un rapprochement où en
êtes-vous de se rapprochement comment
travaillez-vous avec la recette comment
travaillez-vous aussi avec les autres
autorités indépendantes la CNIL et je
voudrais aussi citer Lancy car on voit
le net les questions de cyber
pornographie cyber-harcèlement c'est de
la cybersécurité donc tout ça est très
corrélé et je pense que les autorités de
régulation a gagné à travailler de
manière extrêmement étroite quid des
moyens aussi donc vous avez pu
bénéficier à la faveur votre
organisation et comment vous
projetez-vous pour le PLF 2023 je crois
que cette question des moyens est tout à
fait essentielle pour les autorités de
régulation une autre question est sur le
volet nouvelle compétences à
manipulation l'information en tout cas
la régulation par des mois des des
plateformes vous avez évoqué le bilan de
la loi
dite
anti-infox je rappellerai que l'ensemble
de cette commission c'était opposé au
texte chose assez rare à l'époque et
nous d'ailleurs le conseil social avait
invalidé à certains de mesures de ce
texte nous donnons raison pensez-vous
que le DS à l'application
digital vous savez ces actes dans l'État
va vous permettre de substantiellement
améliorer cette régulation des
plateformes pour ma porte en avoir été
rapporté au nom de la commission des
affaires européennes je pense qu'on est
encore en deçà
des en termes de notamment
l'interdiction de la publicité pour les
jeunes enfants la transparence des
algorithmes évalués par des autorités
indépendantes et non pas les plateformes
elles-mêmes je pense qu'il y a encore
des marges de de progression mais malgré
tout pouvez-vous nous en dire quelques
mots un petit mot également sur la lutte
visant à combattre la surexposition des
enfants aux écrans notamment les moins
de 3 ans puisque nous avons voté aussi
ici un texte qui d'ailleurs été repris
dans comme amendement dans le texte
visant à
installer une une
autorisation parentale
avez-vous les moyens de mener ses
campagnes d'information pour les tous
bottines notamment parce que c'était pas
le cas il y a quelques années et comment
vous vous y prenez vous
voilà cette protection des tout-petits
et puis dernière question qui n'a pas
grand chose à voir avec ce que je viens
de d'évoquer
il y a le renouvellement
où de nouvelles candidatures bien sûr
pour France media Monday et Radio France
quelles vont être les critères
dont le CSA va se doter pour procéder à
ces recrutements bien entendu je pose
ces questions dans le respect total de
l'indépendance de l'autorité qui a
procédé à ces recrutements merci
beaucoup monsieur le président David
Assouline
merci monsieur le président
monsieur roc-olivier Mestre de sodexposé
de d'être devant nous comme
régulièrement
comment ça toucher à
ce qu'il est plus possible d'assumer le
fait pour vous de réguler
un cadre audiovisuel et un paysage
audiovisuel alors que tout le monde
législateur et vous-même pensez
que les règles que vous devez faire
appliquer soit obsolète
on commence à toucher aux limites c'est
tout le monde dit la loi de 86 des plus
le cadre adapté
et que vous vous êtes chargé dans le cas
de la loi de 86 de réguler un moment
donné c'est plus possible
et
c'est aussi ce qui s'est passé avec les
différences d'appréciations sur la
fusion TF1 M6
bien entendu que la révolution numérique
a bougé le cadre
mais il y a aucune
règle de la concurrence qu'à bouger donc
l'autorité de la concurrence juge selon
les règles actuelles de façon
impitoyable donc juste parce qu'elle
applique la règle et vous-même être plus
dans l'interprétation c'est parce que
vous êtes moins sous bien des règles qui
apparaissent strictes et donc vous dites
dans c'est possible si il faut aussi ça
ça bon problème c'est que tout le monde
savait que à partir du moment
où TF1 et M6 je parle des deux chaînes
puissantes
fusionner c'est pas en cédant les autres
pixels de la TNT que le pluralisme la
diversité
etc aller
se modifier bon donc je pose ce constat
aussi pour vous dédouer parce que ça
commence à être un exercice difficile
donc est-ce que à un moment donné on le
réclame tous on sera pas d'accord
sur quelle nouvelle régulation quelle
nouvelle loi 86 comment l'aménager parce
que on a un certain nombre à dire qu'il
faudra
limiter des concentrations trop
puissantes donc au contraire il faudra
aller jeunesse mais en tous les cas j'ai
entendu un message qui venant de
président de l'Autorité de la
concurrence
apparaît tout à fait important qu'il
faudra un moment réfléchir à dans cette
histoire faut davantage de la
concurrence des plateformes étrangères
qui fragilisent nos entreprises et
l'autre marché est-ce que
nous nous orientons vers pour permettre
cette concurrence on se met sur leurs
règles et on fait que nos entreprises et
les mêmes avantages que ces plateformes
ou est-ce que au fur et l'inverse
c'est-à-dire qu'on oblige ses
plateformes dans le cadre européen et
dans le cadre français à rentrer
surdocritères qui préservent la
diversité l'exception culturelle etc
bien entendu c'est la deuxième option
qui à mon avis devrait faire réfléchir
législateur en tous les cas moi je
l'attends à un moment donné un cri
d'alarme de l'archange auprès des
pouvoirs publics
sur le fait que ça devient difficile
pour vous
de réguler dans un cadre que tout le
monde
proclame obsolète
c'est quand même à vous de le dire
donc on va le dire aussi
sur une deuxième question parce que dans
votre bilan
puisqu'on parle aussi du bilan de tout
ce que vous avez eu à traiter
vous avez bien constaté plus que
d'autres que il y a eu une polémique
Kaby en exergue notre commission
d'enquête aussi
aborder plusieurs sujets
chef d'info ou chef d'opinion
et la convention que vous avez signé
avec ces news je vais pas la relire les
devants
est très clair sur et c'est une chaîne
d'information et qu'elle a des
obligations de promouvoir la lutte
contre les discriminations la diversité
etc bon or vous les avez condamnés à
plusieurs reprises je vais passer les
épisodes des gradations des
condamnations et ça serait bien
d'éclairer le législateur
quand il y a un bilan de votre activité
sur qui contrevient
embêtant en face voilà c'est nous c'est
tant de fois cadal c'est tant de fois là
où il y a zéro pour d'autres
et notamment
quand
excusez-moi c'est toujours compliqué
et notamment
oui oui ça va
je suis pas sûr que Google et apprécié
les couleurs précédents alors le 17 mai
dernier
Pascal Praud dans son démission dit
Eric Zemmour avait mis au cœur de la
société française de sa campagne
électorale ces sujets-là on les a
développés sur cette antenne on avait
envie parfois de défendre cette identité
française ces beurre c'est coutume ses
habitudes donc y compris quand c'est
avoué publiquement
que on a défendu d'opinion et en plus un
candidat à la présidentielle qu'il est
véhiculé ça aurait pu pas être
complètement le cas
voilà donc je demande je demande
est-ce que si on a de quoi payer des
abords
parce qu'on comprend bien
est-ce que ça suffit pour pouvoir
continuer à faire ce qu'on veut pas être
ça arrive souvent dans la société hein
je suis riche je peux
peut me passer des règles parce que je
peux payer mais d'être dans
quelle et quand ça continue quand ça
contrevient quand c'est aussi cynique
parfois parce que on fait comme si cette
puissance ne peut pas être arrêtée
à quel moment et de quelle façon vous
pouvez faire stopper quelque chose qui
n'est pas sur l'audiovial public
j'aurais posé une question mais je pense
que
j'aurais bien aimé que vous nous disiez
vous savez qu'on a eu un débat sur le
financement on a un financement on va
dire entre guillemets assuré par la TVA
une portion de la TVA pendant deux ans
ensuite bon quel est votre sentiment
parce que notamment sur le fait que
c'est bien le financement pérenne
est stable qui permet l'indépendance de
l'audiovisuel public et que nous sommes
inquiets nous avons montré ici qu'on
avait une inquiétude là
Monique de Marco merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur c'est un
sujet que vous avez déjà abordé au début
de votre présentation et je reviens sur
celui-ci cela concerne donc le rapport
de la délégation aux droits des femmes
qui a mené des travaux sur l'industrie
pornographique
plusieurs pistes donc ont été proposées
pour encadrer ce milieu et en
particulier la mission propose de
confier à l'arcom de prononcer des sous
fonctions administratives avec des
montants très visuasifs et imposés au
site porno l'affichage d'écran noir tant
que l'âge de l'internaute n'a pas été
vérifiée vous avez répondu en partie en
disant que vous avez bloqué cette sites
mais là c'est une demande de vraiment de
sanction beaucoup plus importante et la
deuxième donc proposition
demande que les préconisations de la com
soient renforcées c'est-à-dire
assermenter les agents de larcome afin
de leur permettre de constater eux-mêmes
les infractions ici pornographiques
accessibles aux mineurs puisque le
possédé actuellement est trop long et
pas assez réactif voilà mes deux
questions que pensez-vous de ces deux
propositions
merci Messieurs les Présidents alors
deux questions la première sur le DA
plus vous n'avez parlé mais la feuille
de route 2020 2023 prévoyait donc le
déploiement de la radio date plus et
vous avez dit d'ailleurs que à cause du
covid ça avait été voilà ça a été un peu
décalé est-ce que vous pourriez
légèrement détailler ce que vous avez
dit dans votre présentation initiale ça
c'est la première question la deuxième
question concerne les offres de services
de distribution de communication
audiovisuelle ce qu'on appelle aussi bon
les bouquets etc vous notez dans votre
rapport que
ces offres passent de 74 à 66 soit une
baisse de 11%, on est encore très en
dessous des chiffres de 2019 qu'elle
appréciation portez-vous sur l'évolution
de ces offres de services de
communication individuel pourquoi un tel
un tel changement est-ce que c'est
structurel est-ce que c'est conjoncturel
voilà mes deux mes deux questions
Céline Brulin merci
monsieur le Président vous avez évoqué
le la suppression de la redevance et je
vous rejoins et on a un certain nombre à
vous rejoindre sur ce que vous avez
développé c'est à dire que on aurait
besoin d'une réflexion de grande ampleur
sur le sens les objectifs de
l'audiovisuel public avant même de
trancher la nature et le volume de son
financement
mais dans le contexte nouveau créé
est-ce que vous travaillez d'ores et
déjà parce qu'il y a dans ce nouveau
paysage la question de la pérennité et
du financement assuré à terme ou pas de
l'audiovisuel public et il y a la
question de l'indépendance est-ce que
d'ores et déjà vous travaillez à des
pistes qui dans le nouveau contexte créé
permettre de garantir l'indépendance de
l'audiovisuel public qui est aujourd'hui
financée d'une manière différente pour
au moins un court terme deuxième
question vous avez évoqué les délais
extrêmement contraints et vous avez
insisté sur la le caractère très
contraint de délai de des nouvelles
autorisations
autour de la fusion avortée de TF1 et de
M6 est-ce que ces délais peuvent être
desserrés
et si ça n'est pas le cas ça laisse
quand même le sentiment
que tout ça était
un peu ficelé
et que
il y a eu un coup de théâtre absolument
inattendu qui fait qu'on est aujourd'hui
dans cette situation là et enfin vous
avez évoqué la nécessité de dégager des
financements très importants vous avez
évoqué le privé mais aussi l'audiovisuel
public et de dégager des capacités oui
d'investissement pour les uns comme pour
les autres mais lorsqu'on regarde
toujours sur le dossier TF1 M6
la proportion de ce que TF1 ou M6 mette
pour élaborer leur grille de programmes
en parallèle de ce que mes Netflix
pour alimenter sa plateforme on est dans
des échelles d'un ordre de grandeur
complètement différente et donc dans les
réflexions à avoir sur les
bouleversements en cours dans le paysage
médiatique audiovisuel etc il y a aussi
ce sujet là c'est à dire que on peut
imaginer toutes les fusions qu'on veut
en clair ça fait pas du tout le poids
par rapport aux plateformes comme celle
que je viens de citer merci
et enfin dernière
merci je voudrais voir une petite
précision et le regard que vous portez
sur cette fameuse MFA
c'était quand même une compétence
nationale et qui devient européenne
j'aimerais pour venir un petit peu nous
éclairer deuxième chose vous avez parlé
des mises en demeure pour la protection
des mineurs mais dans son rapport
l'arcom a une action aussi en faveur de
l'éducation médias l'information
des jeunes et vous dites qu'elle s'est
intensifié ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire un petit peu plus sur cette
éducation après cette question Annette
vous savez que les télé locales qui
participent quand même au pluralisme
donc on a
augmenté le seuil on a demandé
d'ailleurs davantage de 12 à 19 millions
d'habitants est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est suffisant et qu'on doit encore
réclamer plus maintenant et enfin
vous savez qu'on a eu une mission
une mission sur la concentration des
médias qui s'est beaucoup intéressé
d'ailleurs à la à la déontologie des
médias mais est-ce que vous pensez quand
même on devrait aller un peu plus loin
et s'interroger sur la déontologie
carrément des journalistes puisque j'ai
même entendu hier
notre vice-présidente Laurence Rossignol
dire dans une interview que un
journaliste que eux bénéficiaient d'un
code déontologie le journaliste
d'ailleurs à part branché est parvenu de
Fuste qui est pas tout à fait le cas
et je vais oublier le groupe LR donc Max
Brisson
non président
des paroles et tout à l'heure leur
d'Archos est temporaire sur des sujets
très précis mais j'ai souhaité prendre
la parole après l'intervention de
Monique de Marco pour appuyer ce qu'elle
a dit
et pour compléter ce que vous nique de
Marco a dit je voudrais d'abord vous
remercier président d'avoir cité
abondamment dans votre intervention
préliminaire le rapport de la délégation
au droit des femmes approuvé hier
après-midi et publié hier soir
et de revenir en quelques mots sur ce
rapport et sur ce qu'il dit sur la
protection des mineurs vis-à-vis de
l'industrie de la pour nous café
dans les préconisations dans les
recommandations du rapport certaines
concerne donc les médias avec par
exemple la mise en place de contrôle
parental automatique Monique de barcoon
a cité d'autres et surtout dans les
recommandations il y a un renforcement
des moyens pour la com et vous avez dans
votre intervention plus globalement
indiquée exceptionnellement vous
demanderiez des moyens supplémentaires
pour l'Autorité de régulation donc ma
question est simple en complément de
s'imposer par unique de Marco l'autorité
a-t-elle déjà réfléchi
au moyen ton tel aurait besoin pour
lutter contre ce fléau
quelles sont les actions qui pourraient
être enclenchées par ces moyens
supplémentaires par ces agents
seraient-ils nécessaires qu'ils soient
assermenté par exemple pour être en
capacité de véritablement réduire ce qui
est un fléau que le rapport met en
exergue et qui à mon avis doit
interroger l'opinion publique parce
qu'elle ne sera pas compte de
l'importance croissante de l'exposition
des enfants et des adolescents à des
scènes pour nos graphiques donc au sujet
complexe je n'attends pas de vous des
réponses précises mais simplement
peut-être l'état de la réflexion sur le
sujet de l'autorité de la régulation
je vais vous laisser monsieur le
Président de répondre à cette question
je sais qu'il y a d'autres orateurs qui
se sont inscrits qui viendront
interviendront par la suite
ou pour l'ensemble de ces questions qui
manifestent bien l'intérêt des membres
de votre commission pour nos sujets
sur les mineurs par rapport aux écrans
je sais que c'est un thème de
progression qui vous est cher c'est un
domaine sur lequel on déploie une série
d'actions je vais revenir sur le cas
spécifique du des sites pornographiques
dans quelques minutes donc il y a
plusieurs dispositions qui sont en cours
il y a la loi sur le contrôle parental
qui a été adopté l'année dernière à ce
qu'on appelait la loi Studer qui donne
alors pour le coup une compétence à la
NFR et non pas à l'arcom pour veiller à
la façon dont les équipements entiers
mettent en place les dispositifs pour
avoir un dispositif de contrôle parental
par par défaut de notre côté il y a il y
a les campagnes que vous connaissez
enfants et écran on est en train de sur
lequel on est en train de d'actualiser
les choses on a les campagnes de
politique qu'on fait tous les ans bien
connus des Français pour bien cibler les
programmes et leurs horaires on a
déployé en liaison avec la recette et le
gouvernement incite qui s'appelle je
protège mon enfant qui permet d'informer
aisément les familles à la fois sur les
dispositifs de contrôle parental parce
qu'ils sont très nombreux comme vous le
savez pratiquement un dispositif par
type d'équipement mais plus globalement
sur la problématique
de protection des
enfants par rapport aux écrans donc
c'est vraiment un axe un axe d'action
constante de notre institution et c'est
complété bien sûr c'est le sénateur par
une action en matière d'éducation médias
l'occasion de rencontrer le nouveau
ministre de l'éducation au début du mois
de septembre on va d'ailleurs actualiser
notre convention avec l'Éducation
nationale pour bien embrasser non
seulement l'éducation médias au sens
traditionnel du terme mais également les
nouvelles compétences qui sont les
nôtres en matière de régulation des
réseaux sociaux parce que il faut une
action coercitive bien sûr mais il faut
aussi apprendre au plus tôt à utiliser
ces réseaux en citoyens pas simplement
se lâcher parce qu'on est caché par
l'anonymat et également mettre dans
cette convention les thématiques de
lutte contre le contre le piratage qu'il
a aussi doivent s'apprendre ça prend
plus tôt c'est également une action pour
laquelle on a donné élargi la mission de
nos représentations en région les arcoms
qui sont en région pour leur demander
d'être en articulation avec les recteurs
des académies dans lesquels ils sont et
avec tous les médias locaux pour les
inciter là aussi aller plus loin en
matière d'éducation médias nous
développons les actions de formation des
enseignants notamment à Paris on a par
exemple un partenariat et trois avec les
lecteur de Créteil et donc nous
accueillons régulièrement des
enseignants et puis nous mettons à
disposition ça va on va monter en gamme
si je puis dire des modules sur notre
site à disposition des enseignants pour
qu'ils puissent développer leur action
leur action d'éducation aux médias
madame randosay alors le DSA
je voudrais quand même souligner la
chance que nous avons d'être sur un
continent qui s'attache à mettre en
place une régulation des réseaux sociaux
c'est le continent européen et l'actuel
Commission en particulier
ouvre la voie sont un peu pionniers et
sont les premiers pour inventer un
modèle de régulation qui à la fois soit
protecteur de nos valeurs la liberté de
communication au premier chef puisque on
voit certes des excès sur ces réseaux
mais c'est aussi des outils de
communication très très importants ils
font partie de notre vie quotidienne à
tous et en même temps de mieux répondre
aux attentes des opinions publiques
d'une plus grande protection
donc c'est un texte qui est ambitieux
c'est un texte qui est complexe vous le
connaissez bien puisque vous avez
beaucoup travaillé de dessus il y a de
très gros enjeux de mise en oeuvre il y
a de très gros enjeux d'abord pour la
Commission européenne Allemagne
puisqu'il va falloir qu'elle se note
elle aussi d'un outil pour mettre en
œuvre les dispositions de ce texte
on parle d'un service qui nous vaut qui
sera créé on aura nous-mêmes dès la
semaine prochaine des contacts avec les
services de la Commission sur ce point
et puis il va falloir organiser la
gouvernance de ce règlement européen
donc ce bordel qui est associé à les
autorités de régulation nationale
j'y vois une petite difficulté que je
vous cache pas même si on salue on salue
le texte c'est problématiques de contenu
illicite sur les réseaux sociaux c'est
des problématiques qui sont d'une
hypersensibilité nationale d'ailleurs
vous-même
juste titre vous exprimez en tant qu'élu
de la de la nation quand vous êtes
interpellé ou quand vous constatez des
excès et la difficulté de cette
gouvernance c'est que c'est une
gouvernance qui préserve le pays
d'implantation
des sites et donc les régulateurs des
pays où sont implantés ces sites et qui
centralisent beaucoup le dispositif au
niveau de la Commission et donc je pense
qu'on va avoir ça c'est un gros sujet à
évoquer avec la commission comment on
articule bien les préoccupations locales
celles que nous au régulateurs nationaux
régulateur national on va avoir pour
répondre aux préoccupations des opinions
publiques nationales et le fait que la
gestion de ce dispositif et lointain ça
c'est la première difficulté que je vois
la deuxième difficulté je vois c'est la
nature de la régulation en matière de
télévision vous êtes intervenu plusieurs
pour me poser des questions sur le sujet
un programme ne vous plaît pas
sur tel ou telle chaîne monsieur
Assouline a évoqué une chaîne qui lui
est chère bon il peut nous interpeller
il manque pas de le faire d'autres le
font on examine les programmes on
regarde si c'est conforme à la loi ou
pas si c'est conforme à la Convention ou
pas et on déploie les outils que nous
avons sur ces réseaux sociaux qui
brassent des centaines de millions
d'informations chaque seconde on peut
pas courir après chaque contenu les uns
après les autres c'est donc ce qu'on
appelle une régulation systémique que
cet axe et notamment le DSA mettent en
place et des obligations de moyens qui
vont être imposées à ces grands acteurs
qui donneront à la Commission en
articulation avec les régulateurs
nationaux la mission de s'assurer que
ces moyens sont bien mis en oeuvre et
s'ils ne sont pas mis en oeuvre la
possibilité de sanctionner qui met trois
également en œuvre des dispositifs
d'audit extérieur pour voir ce que font
effectivement les plateformes et puis
qui imposeront aussi à des acteurs une
obligation de transparaître transparence
et d'accès à leur donner et notamment à
leurs algorithmes pour voir comment ça
comment ça fonctionne donc le texte va
dans le bon sens incontestablement je
pense c'est une belle initiative de
l'Union européenne et il faut saluer le
fait conditions incontinent pionnier en
la matière mais ça va être un art
d'exécution et le sens du message que je
que je veux exprimer
sur notre organisation sur laquelle vous
avez posé une question donc je l'ai
indiqué on a revu notre organigramme à
la fois en créant une direction des
plateformes en ligne pour gérer nos
nouvelles compétences et quand j'ai
parlé de renforcement de moyens c'est
cette direction que j'évoque en
particulier
j'avais déjà je crois évoqué devant vous
mais j'ai revu récemment une
communication de homologues anglais qui
pour la régulation des plateformes
parlent d'un service de 300 agents
honnêtement d'ailleurs je me demande ce
qu'ils feront 300 c'est quand même
beaucoup mais bon
nous sommes aujourd'hui avec une
direction qui est encore en moyenneur et
les renforcements de moyens ont pour but
voilà de que cette direction des
plateformes en ligne puisse bien gérer
les nouveaux taxes divers qui sont les
nôtres et puis on a créé une direction
de la création donc qui mêle la gestion
des obligations de financement qui
pèsent sur les acteurs de l'audiovisuel
et les plateformes de vidéos par
abonnement jusqu'à la lutte contre le
piratage
quant à leur cèpe bien noté
l'idée d'une fusion ne vous effrayez pas
donc je vous remercie de
vouloir étendre le domaine de la lutte
pour l'arcom
bon digérons déjà la première fusion
nous avons une très bonne relation avec
la recette globalement une très très
bonne relation avec l'ensemble des
autorités indépendantes on se réunit
périodiquement on a d'ailleurs une
réunion la semaine prochaine je crois
avec l'ensemble de nos homologues donc
on se réduit une fois par semaine chez
les autres pour faire un tour d'horizon
il y a deux jours nous avons réuni
ensemble les deux collèges comme nous le
faisons une fois par semaine le collège
de la recette et du CSA et de l'arcom
pardon pour balayer nos sujets d'intérêt
commun on a un service commun alors
cette et alors comme sur une série de
sujets j'irai moi-même devant le collège
de la CNIL prochainement pour exposer un
peu les nouvelles missions et voir les
thématiques de dialogue donc voilà il y
a une collaboration qui est vraiment
très bonne j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
l'Autorité de la concurrence on aurait
tort de vouloir nous opposer à
l'autorité la concurrence avec laquelle
la collaboration est très fluide très
très confiante
et très homogène je dirais même si
chacun a son champ de compétence plus
particuliers
sur France media monde et Radio France
donc nous sommes dans la phase d'appel à
candidature comme vous le savez l'appel
sera clos le 21 octobre se faire hors de
ma part si ma mémoire ne me fait pas
défaut
nous publierons ensuite la liste des
candidatures recevables nous publierons
également les projets stratégiques
puisque la loi impose que chaque
candidat présente un projet stratégique
à l'appui de ça de sa candidature donc
mènerons cela en pleine transparence
nous ferons ensuite des auditions
publiques des candidats
la loi nous fixe comme critère
l'expérience et la compétence et les
deux critères qui sont mentionnés dans
la loi de 86 donc on veillera bien
évidemment aller les appliquer et nous
statuons au plus tard
nous avons donné cette date publiquement
au plus tard le 15 janvier c'est-à-dire
avant le prochain renouvellement du
collège puisque vous savez pas de
collège sur nouvelle partie à tous les
deux ans donc deux membres vont nous
quitter en janvier de l'année prochaine
pour être remplacé donc on souhaite
statuer sur ce dossier qui est déjà
enclenché avec le collège actuel nous
d'où ce calendrier de de décision
monsieur le sénateur Assouli on nous
avons déjà souvent et longuement
dialogué sur les questions que vous avez
soulevées et notamment devant la
commission d'enquête sur la sur la
concentration à laquelle nous avons
activement participé nous avions fourni
énormément de matière pour votre commune
Commission on a été redevoir qu'elle
avait été utilisée à profit dans le
rapport de la de la de la Commission
alors la loi de 86 est-elle
définitivement obsolète
vous connaissez ma position je suis plus
nuancée que vous ou pas pas seulement
parce que j'ai un attachement
particulier à cette loi vous le savez
mais simplement parce que je pense que
les principes qui font de cette loi je
serai tenté de dire beaucoup de choses
hier je dis pas que tout y a beaucoup de
choses hier restent d'une actualité vous
êtes très attaché et je le suis tout
autant que vous à la défense du
pluralisme c'est un principe cardinal de
cette loi elle est tout à fait tout à
fait valable je pense qu'elle a deux
faiblesses cette fois c'est qu'elle a
été modifiée comme vous le savez j'ai
jamais le chiffre à peu près 80 fois
donc au bout d'un moment sa lisibilité
est plus tout à fait donc j'ai eu
l'occasion d'échanger avec le président
Steam pour la de la Commission de
codification le premier travail très
utile serait une codification de cette
loi on a un code
qui résume très clairement les règles
qui sont en vigueur parce que et pour
vous et pour nous et pour le juge je
crois que ça serait pour les
usagers sera quand même extrêmement
utile et puis
moi j'ai pas de stylité à l'idée
d'engager un moment la refonte de ce
texte c'est vraiment
bon voilà il a 40 ans d'histoire
pourquoi pas mais bon courage
bon courage
je vous reprends quand même sur
j'ai cru sentir que vous souhaitiez
proposer l'arcom et l'AdlC et donc ça je
voudrais vraiment m'inscrire en faux
là-dessus il y aurait en quelque sorte
une autorité vertueuse qui serait
l'Autorité de la concurrence et puis
notoriété qui serait moins larcode je
sais vous lire monsieur le sénateur
placez je vous connais depuis les années
je vous connais bien je sais je sais
décrypter vos propos je vois très bien
le sous-titrage je vois très bien le
sous-titrage
on applique des règles strictes la PIC
des règles Sinatra non monsieur le
sénateur je peux pas laisser dire ça les
gars
d'une autorité indépendante c'est un
collège qui statue et c'est autorité
applique appliquera les lois vous
commentiez notre action c'est tout à
fait normal c'est le rôle de la
représentation nationale je rendais
compte devant vous vous pouvez tout à
fait estimer que notre action mais je
peux pas laisser dire qu'il y a une
autorité qui staturait en pleine
indépendance parce que c'est ce que vous
avez sous-entendre et une autorité qui
ne l'aurait pas fait donc je voulais
très clairement nous avons eu une
appréciation et je vous mets au défi je
vous mets au défi de savoir ce que nous
aurions décidé sur le changement de
contrôle de ces groupes puisque nous
n'avons pas statué là-dessus donc vous
ne pouvez pas par définition savoir
quelle position l'autorité aurait pris
sur ce sur ce sujet donc on n'est pas
sur nous notre feuille de route je le
dis je le redis si je reviens toujours
la seule feuille de route et chaque fois
qu'il y a une décision difficile à
prendre et Dieu sait s'il y en a dans
cet autorité ma seule feuille de route
c'est la loi chaque fois je reprends la
loi de 86 je relis le tail je relis les
intentions législateur c'est ça notre
boussole c'est pas d'interprétation
c'est pas l'air du temps comment je
perçois les choses est-ce que ça serait
bien pas bien non que dit la loi la loi
nous charge de défendre le pluralisme au
sens large et bien sûr cette opération
c'est ce que nous aurions fait et dans
notre avis à l'Autorité de la
concurrence nous avons
identifié des risques nous les avons
nous avons très clairement très
clairement exposés sur le dieu visuel
public je pense qu'on a une approche qui
est pas très différente depuis de
nombreuses années là aussi on en a parlé
un nous sommes les avocats du service
public service public sont un rôle
fondamental pour la cohésion nationale
en matière d'information de
divertissement d'accès à la culture de
soutien à la création
c'est un élément d'équilibre du paysage
et donc nous sommes les avocats de cette
entité publique qui joue un rôle
vraiment fondamental et nous avons
toujours nous étions attachés à un
financement pérenne qui donne de la
visibilité à ces entreprises qui sont
très complexes et très et très
difficiles très difficiles à gérer il y
a une solution nous aurions préféré pour
notre part vous le savez qu'on anticipe
sur l'échéance de la taxe d'habitation
et qu'on imagine une réforme de la
redevance parce qu'il fallait réformer
cette redevance c'était pas c'était pas
l'alpha et l'oméga alors redevance c'est
d'ailleurs pas parce qu'il y avait une
redevance que les contributions
publiques on progressait donc la réforme
était souhaitable toute chose égale par
ailleurs le modèle qui nous aurait
plutôt plus à leur que c'était le modèle
allemand d'une taxe universelle
déconnectée des appareils avec les
exonérations sociales qui vont bien donc
une assiette plutôt large quitte à jouer
sur sur le taux bon c'est pas le choix
qui a été fait alors comme n'a pas à
discuter ce que le Parlement a décidé le
Parlement a décidé il est souverain ce
que nous souhaitons c'est je l'ai dit et
je réponds je vous réponds madame la
sénatrice c'est que la période qui va
entre maintenant et 2025 soit vraiment
mise à profit pour engager une réflexion
sur le devisole public sur ces missions
sur son organisation notre conviction
c'est qu'il faut aller vers plus de
convergence entre les entreprises le
service public gagnerait rassembler ses
forces pas pour faire de la
rationalisation administrative
mais simplement pour être plus efficace
il y a des dossiers sur lesquels je
trouve que il faut que les entreprises
aillent plus loin je pense à l'offre de
proximité avoir une belle grande offre
de proximité de service public dans le
contexte de concurrence local d'acteurs
privés est un enjeu très important pour
le service public avoir une offre
numérique plus homogène de la part du
service public ça me paraît un enjeu
commun qui est fondamental avoir une
stratégie commune en direction des
publics les plus jeunes c'est une
ambition commune et ma deuxième
conviction c'est que si on laisse
simplement les entreprises en leur
disant soyez gentils collaborer entre
vous les choses n'avanceront pas
des entreprises qui ont des corps
sociaux très très forts
légitime avec un historique très
particulier donc si on veut organiser
cette convergence si on estime que cette
orientation est la bonne je pense que ça
suppose effectivement à un moment de
réfléchir sur la façon dont on pilote
l'organisation de cette de cette
convergence
alors et monsieur le sénateur à souligne
sur cnews on est intervenus je vais pas
revenir dessus parce qu'on en a parlé
très longuement devant la commission
d'enquête pourrait reprendre largement
mes propos
nous sommes intervenus et nous
interviendrons sur cette chaîne comme
sur les autres chaque fois qu'il y aura
un manquement un contenu nous le ferons
dans le cadre des principes qui sont
posés par la voie de 86
je rappelle que l'institution a quand
même 40 ans d'histoire et que nous avons
donc plus de 40 ans de jurisprudence du
Conseil d'État de la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme donc on sait à peu
près où se situe le curseur entre la
liberté d'expression et les
interventions qu'on peut faire au titre
des sanctions sûrement peut-être mieux
faire et donc
les autorisations comme vous savez elles
ont des échéances j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de dire de vente de
commission et dans les critères de
renouvellement des autorisations il y a
une phase de bilan sur la façon dont les
conventions étaient exécutées et
notamment sur les procédures de sanction
que le régulateur a pu être amené à
mettre en œuvre au titre de au titre de
la convention donc c'est un paramètre
c'est pas le seul c'est un paramètre
parmi d'autres je crois que c'était
d'ailleurs une piste que vous évoquez
dans votre rapport d'enquête que j'ai lu
très attentivement de la première à la
dernière page y compris les annexes
et donc ça c'est un progrès qui m'a
beaucoup intéressé et je redis devant
vous puisque plusieurs m'ont posé la
question que nous-mêmes je l'avais dit
dans la commission d'enquête nous
appelons de nos vœux à une adaptation du
droit de la régulation le paysage se
transforme
je crois que l'opération convient de
qu'on vient de vivre montre que tout de
même les outils fonctionnent les outils
de régulation qui fonctionnent et les
règles anti concentration qui
fonctionnent mais ça doit pas nous
empêcher de nous projeter vers l'avenir
il y a un nouveau champ digital nous
avons fait des propositions nous-mêmes
pour que le régulateur que nous sommes
vois ces compétences un peu élargies et
transformées en la matière votre rapport
à des choses sur la table il y a des
états généraux de l'information qui vont
bientôt se tenir ce sera probablement
l'occasion de redébattre de ces sujets
et de voir
pardon
ainsi qu'un modeste président d'autorité
c'est pas vraiment du gouvernement
une réponse quand même sur la sur les
sites
je suis quand même frappé que le
législateur est intervenu il y a deux
ans maintenant la loi sur les violences
conjugales donc août 2020 si ma mémoire
est bonne
nous sommes en septembre 2021
ça me rappeler 22 donc plus de 2 ans
sont écoulés
aucun site n'a pris une initiative pour
se mettre en conformité avec la loi
française
nous les avons mis en demeure
peuvent pas dire qu'ils n'ont pas été
alerté
ils se contestent notre mise en demeure
devant le Conseil d'État
ils ont présenté une question
prioritaire de constitutionnalité devant
le Conseil d'État qui est en cours
d'examen
notre mise en demeure et bien évidemment
été précédé de constat d'ici on
s'assurer de l'état de l'état des lieux
on a refait des constats après nos mises
en demeure on a vu que rien n'avait
bougé on a saisi la justice
à nouveau une question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité a été posée devant le
tribunal judiciaire sur lequel le
tribunal répondra le 30 septembre je
crois que faire de ma part donc on verra
si elle est transmise à la courte
cassation pour examen éventuellement
derrière au Conseil constitutionnel
pour vous dire qu'on est en face de nous
les acteurs qui feront flèches de tout
bois et ça j'étais très sensible à ce
qui a été dit dans le rapport de la
délégation hier soir sur cette notion
d'industrie l'industrie puissante
donc le régulateur met en oeuvre les
dispositions que le Sénat puisque c'est
un amendement de la sénatrice Mercier
qui a été adopté en l'occurrence sur ces
mises en demeure sur la saisie de la
justice maintenant là-bas elle est dans
le camp de la justice on va voir ce que
la procédure de médiation va donner nous
aurions pour notre part souhaité c'est
ce qu'on avait demandé au tribunal qui
l'utilise ça faculté de bloquer les
sites purement et simplement parce que
notre conviction c'est que tant qu'il y
aura pas une contrainte se mettront pas
pleinement en mouvement mais on a là une
procédure de médiation donc on va jouer
le jeu on sera présent nous-mêmes à la
médiation
quand on renfort pourquoi pas les
sanctions financières
soldifient la grosse difficulté que j'y
vois et d'ailleurs nous nous le voyons
dans la mise en oeuvre de ces
dispositions c'est que c'est des sites
qui sont pour la plupart hors de France
sur ce que nous assignons il y en a qui
sont à Chypre il y en a qui sont
opportuns il y en a qui sont check-in
donc chaque fois il faut qu'on a une
notifié c'est pas au bureau de poste d'à
côté que se fait l'accusé de réception
c'est à l'autre bout de l'Union il faut
qu'on informe la Commission européenne
parce qu'on est dans le cadre européen
donc c'est des procédures qui sont qui
sont quand même très lourdes
bon en tout cas je vais prendre
connaissance du rapport on réagira sur
l'ensemble des professions on a
contribué à cette mission de la
délégation au roi des femmes
les services de l'arcome avaient répondu
aux auditions
les choses bougent quand même la justice
bouge vous l'avez vu quand même il y a
plusieurs procédures qui sont en cours
des enquêtes qui qui conduisent même à
des incarcérations donc voilà on sent
que l'opinion publique a beaucoup évolué
par rapport à ce qui prévalait ce qui
prévalait il y a quelques années il
faudra très vraisemblablement aller plus
loin
l'audiovisuel public madame la salatrice
je crois que je vous je crois que je
vous ai répondu monsieur le sénateur
barjoton sur la sur le DAB+ alors le
petit retard qu'on a pris bien sûr la
pandémie et lie un peu la crise qu'on
vit en ce moment sur les composants
puisque pour ces matériels de diffusion
il faut des composants et comme vous le
savez il y a une pénurie qui est assez
forte bon donc on est actualisé notre
feuille de route on espère quand même je
le disais tout à l'heure toucher 50% de
la population française fin 2023 donc
les grandes agglomérations sont
couvertes les grands axes routiers
devraient être couverts et après on
complètera progressivement le puzzle
pour tous les Français y a accès vous
avez raison sur les bouquets c'est une
tendance un peu générale que qu'on
observe donc
il faut à la fois veiller à la pluralité
des acteurs bien sûr c'est un élément
qui est important mais en même temps la
compétitivité du du secteur le point de
vigilance pour nous c'est ce mouvement
de
désintermédiation comme disent les
techniciens entre les éditeurs et les
consommateurs qui se développent donc
votre question est très pertinente c'est
en tout cas un point de un point de
vigilance pour nous
sur la suppression de la redevance
monsieur je crois largement largement
exprimé
l'AMFA alors la mfage un peu tenté comme
le DSA de saluer cette initiative
européenne c'est quand même bien que le
continent européen se dot
un dispositif pour mieux protéger la
liberté d'informer la liberté de
communication
s'intéresser au sujet de concentration
de concentration dans les médias
c'est un texte qui s'est beaucoup
développé entre les idées de départ les
idées de départ visé plutôt quelques
problèmes particuliers sur la frontière
orientale du continent j'allais dire et
puis finalement on est parti sur un
texte qui est beaucoup plus ambitieux
ça sera un peu comme le DSA ça va être
un ordre d'exécution parce que c'est un
texte qui n'embrasse pas que les médias
audiovisuel mais qui embrassent aussi la
presse écrite vous connaissez
l'indépendance farouche de la presse
écrite et on ne peut que la soutenir
bien évidemment donc rentrer dans un
dispositif de régulation on sera
sûrement un élément de un élément de
débat et une deuxième question c'est que
les pays de l'Union ont des corpus
juridiques très différents la France un
corpus très avancé insuffisamment
peut-être mais en tout cas en matière de
règles anticoncentration en matière de
protection de la presse avec la loi de
1880 la loi 86 pour les médiocres de
visuels d'autres pays n'ont pas ses
règles et donc l'acceptation d'une
supranationale pour tous les acteurs de
l'union sera sûrement délicate et puis
comme pour le DSA il y aura un problème
de gouvernance puisque le texte un
élément positif c'est qu'il prévoit que
le réseau des régulateurs européens dans
lesquels nous sommes donc les regards
deviendraient en quelques recettes en
quelque sorte le conseil je peux quel
est son nom le conseil
conseil des médias enfin c'est lui qui
serait l'instant mais en même temps dans
le texte on voit bien que la Commission
européenne exerce à l'égard de ce
conseil une corde de rappel j'ose pas
dire tutélaire mais quand même assez
forte donc si on veut une régulation des
médias il faut une régulation
indépendante comme ça que nous exerçons
avec les règles de protection de notre
indépendance qui s'y attache donc belle
initiative belle idée un long débat en
perspective au Parlement européen et
entre les États européens et un ordre
d'exécution certainement très très
important sur les télévisions locales
pense le sol vient d'être bougé par le
par le Parlement donc laissons vivre ce
seuil je pense qu'il faut faire
attention aux équilibres entre le
développement des acteurs privés en
télévision
notre souhait c'est toujours de voilà la
question du pluralisme c'est préservons
la pluralité du modèle des télévisions
locales il y a des télévisions privées
groupe Altis en particulier qui se
développe avec BFM il y a des
télévisions articulaires avec la presse
quotidienne régionale on a validé
l'année dernière la reprise par la
dépêche un réseau de dans le Sud-Ouest
parce que ça nous paraît important
d'appliquer la presse il y a des
télévisions qui sont totalement
indépendantes en liaison avec les
concerts régionaux et puis il y a le
service public donc je pense qu'il faut
veiller à garder c'est de pluralité pour
avoir vraiment des modèles des modèles
différents
la déontologie des journalistes
va se programme on aurait dit le général
c'est bon c'est un sujet c'est un sujet
récurrent un sujet récurrent mais en
même temps très très délicat
la loi pour l'instant je le répète
souvent ne flèche pour nous que les
personnalités politiques c'est ce que
dit l'article 13 de la voie de 86 donc
notre contrôle outil du planisme
s'exerce que sur les personnalités
politiques certains voudraient qu'on
aille plus loin que ça touche les
éditorialistes
pour l'instant ce n'est pas ce que dit
la loi et moi type personnel j'estime
qu'il faut être très prudent dans cette
voie là on défend assez jamais assez à
mes yeux la liberté et la liberté
d'expression dans les limites qui sont
naturellement posées posées par la loi
sur le renforcement de nos moyens j'en
ai donné quelques indications donc dans
le projet de loi de finance pour l'année
prochaine on prévoit d'augmenter notre
subvention d'un million 8
ce qui nous permettrait donc de recruter
15 collaborateurs donc c'est un état qui
nous on vient en espérant qu'il soit
suivi encore d'une étape supplémentaire
l'année suivante
et sur l'indépendance
de l'audiovisuel public
[Musique]
bon il y a plusieurs éléments de
l'indépendance d'abord le fait que c'est
nous qui nous montrons les dirigeants ça
je crois que c'est quand même important
de garder ce modèle confie un régulateur
indépendant le soin de mai le fait qu'on
donne un avis sur tous les textes qui
intéresse le service public tous les
contrats d'objectifs qu'on donne chaque
année un avis sur l'exécution du contrat
d'objectif et sur le respect du cahier
des charges qui est un travail utile
pour le Parlement savoir bien exercer
son contrôle sur ces entreprises
sur le financement
moi je serai pas choqué que avant le
débat parlementaire sur le financement
de l'audiovisuel public on demande un
avis à l'arcom alors comme une vision
panoramique du secteur pas très bien
l'ensemble des équilibres le privé le
public
il donne un avis sur tous les textes
qu'on a un bloc de compétences qui est
très très homogène très cohérent
pourquoi ne pas voilà solliciter son
avis tous les ans sur le sur le montant
de la redevance ça pourrait être une
contribution je sais qu'il y a d'autres
idées qui ont été avancées monsieur le
sénateur dans un rapport avec le
sénateur carochi il y a quelques il y a
quelques mois
ça peut être en tout cas un élément de
l'éclairage un peu comme le Haut Conseil
des finances publiques par rapport à la
loi de finances qui permet d'avoir un
avis un peu extérieur et d'éclairer le
débat le débat parlementaire
[Musique]
je voudrais juste revenir sur l'une des
nouvelles missions que l'art comme s'est
vu conférer la lutte contre les contenus
et en ligne comme vous avez déjà apporté
un certain nombre d'éléments sur le
sujet je vais être brève vous avez
déployé au mois de juillet une cybertas
force pour lutter contre les violences
numériques et vous avez évoqué à
l'Assemblée nationale à un travail de
signal éthique en la matière pouvez-vous
nous apporter plus de précision sur ce
dispositif et surtout ce type d'action
vous paraît-il assez dissuasif ou courir
City pour pouvoir stopper net un
phénomène qui nécessite une prise en
charge ferme et rapide merci
merci monsieur le Président moi je
voulais revenir sur la difficulté de
mise en oeuvre du décret ce Mad monsieur
le Président car je crois que c'est
simplement du déclaratif pour le moment
pour les plateformes comment l'arcom
peut-elle contrôler les données de
visionnage de téléchargement des coups
de marketing qui permettent la
répartition des obligations entre cinéma
et audiovisuel et question subsidiaire
est-ce que vous avez le droit de
communiquer les montants investis en
prêt-achat et achat en 2021 pour Netflix
Amazon et Disney est-ce que cela
correspond en fait au montant qui était
prévu voilà c'est vrai qu'il passe leur
temps à dire qu'ils veulent avancer sur
la chronologie mais il faut bien
évidemment qu'ils puissent contribuer et
financer enfin participer au financement
du cinéma voilà
question supplémentaire de c'est en fait
une mise au point
parce que il y a eu un échange comme ça
j'ai dit très exactement que les lois de
la concurrence sont strictes donc elles
peuvent être appliquées par une autorité
de régulation
sans interprétation trop importante il y
a toujours
à partir du moment où la loi de 86 est
quasiment obsolètes dans plein de
domaines notamment tout ce qui touche à
ce qui est entre la révolution numérique
et l'audiovisuel
vos interprétations
ne sont pas
quand je dis ou plus grande marge
d'interprétation de ce que cette loi qui
ne régule pas ce secteur veut dire dans
son principe ou avec compris donc je
n'ai pas parlé d'indépendance de votre
jugement
voilà on peut avoir des désaccords c'est
normal mais je n'ai pas parlé
d'indépendance de votre jugement j'ai
parlé du fait que
votre interprétation que que j'ai
contesté mais ça c'est normal et c'est
des êtres humains qui composent votre
collège qui ont aussi leurs
interprétations et
voilà depuis le début vous avez
considéré que c'était nécessaire
vous l'avez dit depuis le début c'était
nécessaire par rapport aux évolutions
d'avoir un géant etc et que ça
n'atteindrait pas forcément bon et
ça c'est nos interprétations mais je
n'ai pas dit que c'était une question
d'indépendance de votre part
juste répondre sur ce point je voudrais
deux questions moi celle qui ont été
voulu juste répondre sur ce point qui
auront
changé sur le sujet je conteste
parfaitement la conclusion je n'ai
jamais dit ça j'ai dit que des groupes
il était normal que des groupes
s'adaptent aux évolutions leur contexte
c'est la logique d'une entreprise qui
soit publique ou privée et un marché qui
évolue c'est normal qu'ils prennent des
initiatives et puis de l'autre côté il y
a la régulation et que la régulation
exacerait dès la première heure j'ai dit
que notre fil rouge serait le pluralise
et que la décision serait prise de façon
que les jardins indépendante j'ai jamais
donné un propos et je vois pas comment
j'aurais pu le dire parce qu'une
décision collégiale disons que cette
opération avait vocation à se faire mais
c'est votre chez votre analyse avant que
vous ne répondiez aux questions de Twin
bourre et de Laure darkos je voudrais en
rajouter deux d'abord vous nous avez dit
il y a quelques minutes que vous pensiez
que la convergence des acteurs du
secteur public était nécessaire mais
elle ne pourrait se faire
sont qui est une impulsion forte est-ce
que de votre point de vue ça veut dire
que les comme sont un outil suffisant ou
pas suffisant pour accélérer et mettre
en oeuvre cette convergence et sur un
autre sujet plus en lien avec la vente
de M6 par rapport à la règle existante
de l'interdiction de vente
suivant le renouvellement des
autorisations est-ce que vous pensez que
cette règle est toujours pertinente et
qu'elle pourrait être la faire évoluer
pour être de nature
ne pas prendre une décision dans la
précipitation comme ça risque d'être le
cas si
leurs intentions de du propriétaire
actuel de M6 c'était
suivi des faits je rappelle que c'était
un des amendements qui avait proposé le
sénateur Hugo
monsieur le Président je vais commencer
par ces dernières questions vous
comprendrez prononcerai pas sur ce
dernier point parce que nous sommes dans
un processus de renouvellement
d'autorisation qui se fait dans un cadre
juridique
donner et que je voudrais pas avoir un
propos donner un sentiment sur une à
l'égard des règles du jeu qui sont les
règles du jeu qui s'appliquent
aujourd'hui et en tant qu'autorité comme
je l'ai dit tout à l'heure notre mission
est d'appliquer la loi telle qu'elle
existe donc cette règle est celle qui
est en vidéo aujourd'hui si par Le Mans
souhaite un moment ou un autre comme il
l'avait fait par le passé se ressaisir
du sujet c'est bien évidemment le droit
souverain du Parlement mais à ce stade
je ne souhaite pas m'exprimer sur ce
sujet je pense pas que les cônes soient
suffisant pour une orientation
stratégique comme celle que j'évoquais
on en a une bonne illustration je trouve
avec les comme en cours d'exécution qui
partaient d'une assez bonne idée
d'ailleurs d'avoir des obligations
spécifique à chaque entreprise et des
obligations communes
laissez la mise en oeuvre à la seule
bonne volonté des entreprises
je crois que c'est se heurte
à des inerties légitimes j'allais dire
d'entreprises qui ont leur logique
propre leur organisation propre leur
contraintes propres et donc il y a
nécessairement pour la mise en œuvre
d'objectifs aussi ambitieux aussi
stratégiques que des actions de
convergence nécessairement besoin de
concevoir une gouvernance spécifique ça
c'est vraiment la conviction que je
retire après quatre ans puisque je
rentre maintenant dans le dernier tiers
de mon mandat
sur les Smart madame la salatrice
d'Arcos donc on est un peu au début
j'allais dire on a signé des conventions
avec ces acteurs on applique strictement
les dispositions du du décret SMAD les
services en question donc sont tenus de
nous déclarer
[Musique]
ce qu'ils ont réalisé au titre de les
dispositions de la Convention et du
Règlement ça nous amène à être tout à
fait exigeant à leur égard
je pense à l'un des acteurs principaux
principaux contributeurs avec lequel on
a eu des échanges nourris qui les ont
obligés à bouger sur leur lit nous
connaissons bien
les préoccupations qui peuvent
s'exprimer qui ne sont pas homogènes
entre le monde de l'audiovisuel et le
monde du cinéma les conventions qu'on a
conclu sont une première étape elles
sont conclus pour trois ans elle ne
préjugue pas d'accord interprol il y a
d'ailleurs des négociations qui sont en
cours qui prend et je le souhaite venir
enrichir les conventions il y a d'autres
éléments de débat qui sont en toile de
fond comme vous le savez qui entrait à
la chronologie des médias
il faudrait pas que que ces acteurs ou
certains d'entre eux prennent des
postures trop raides dans cette dans
cette approche je pense que tout le
monde a intérêt à jouer le jeu de la
négociation et de la négociation
interprofessionnelle
c'est l'intérêt de des plateformes ce
qu'on voit bien que dans leur modèle
exposé les contenus nationaux est un
moyen de fidéliser leurs abonnés
d'élargir leur base c'est l'intérêt de
la filière d'avoir des financements des
financements supplémentaires et en tout
cas comme comme régulateur nous sommes
en dialogue avec les différents acteurs
si un moment il faut faire bouger les
paramètres ou aller plus loin et voir
éventuellement de faire bouger la loi on
reviendra on reviendra vers vous
madame la sénatrice alors c'est bien sûr
un enjeu très très important pour nous
les contenus haineux pour nous la
priorité maintenant c'est la mise en
oeuvre du texte européen le DSA c'est
pour ça qu'on souhaiterait que le
l'autorité nationale qui sera en charge
de la mise en oeuvre du DSA et vous avez
compris que nous serions pas opposés à
être cette autorité puisse en liaison
avec les autres puissent être désigné
puisse être désigné rapidement parce que
c'est un texte complexe il faut aussi
adapter il faut anticiper et de forte
attente de nos concitoyens sur ces
sujets de haine en ligne et de contenu
unicité en tout cas c'est un chantier
sur lequel on souhaite s'impliquer très
fortement
merci monsieur le Président pour
très précise et complète à nous
interrogations et c'est vrai que le
sujet a une actualité permanente et je
ne doute pas que nous aurons sans doute
l'occasion de vous réinterroger
notamment sur la partie audiovisuelle
merci beaucoup en tout cas de cette
présentation
[Musique]